- Welcome, everyone to our webinar on
"How Teaching Kids to Read
Went So Wrong", sponsored by,
Yale's Institution for
Social and Policy Research,
or ISPS for short.
And we're also co-sponsoring this event
with the Yale Education Studies Program.
Our executive director of
that program is Mira Debs,
and so thank you to our co-sponsors.
Before we begin,
I wanna recognize some of
the outstanding colleagues
at ISPS who help organize our events,
especially Pam Greene,
Rick Harrison, and Kira Wishart.
Thank you all so much for
all the support you give
to all of our events.
I'm Alan Gerber.
I'm director of ISPS,
and today I'm excited to
provide an opportunity
for you to hear some of the
insights of Emily Hanford,
an award-winning reporter and podcaster.
I will introduce her shortly.
This event is part of ISPS's
Democratic Innovations Program,
which is designed to
identify and test ideas
for improving the quality
of democratic representation
and governance.
One of the major research
priorities at ISPS
is to understand governance,
and a big part of governance is
how well government services are provided.
Education is a critical
government responsibility,
and so I'm very pleased
that we have a chance
to reflect on how we are
doing at meeting this basic
and essential collective responsibility.
A couple of logistical matters.
Emily's gonna speak for 25 or 30 minutes.
After she's completed her presentation,
I may ask a question or two.
We're then gonna open things
up for general Q and A
that Eric Patashnik will
be helping to manage,
and that the event is gonna
run until around 5:15.
So we have about 75 minutes
to meet together today.
I wanna encourage you
all to send questions
for Emily at any time
through the Q and A Button
at the bottom of your Zoom screen.
Please keep your questions
brief and on topic
and we will do our best to
answer as many as we can.
To help field questions, again,
I don't know, Eric,
I should introduce you a little bit.
Eric is the Julis-Rabinowitz professor
of public policy and
Chair of political science
at Brown University,
and he's an award-winning author of books
on a number of topics in American politics
and public policy and administration.
So thank you Eric for your help today.
I also wanna let everyone know
that today's event is being recorded,
and so we hope to be
able to share the link
for this video as soon as
possible after the event
if you'd like to watch it multiple times.
So let me tell you a little about Emily.
Emily Hanford is a senior correspondent
and producer for American Public Media.
Her work has appeared on "NPR"
and in the "New York Times",
the "Washington Monthly",
the "Los Angeles Times"
and other publications.
She has won numerous honors,
including a duPont-Columbia
University Award, and the,
Excellence in Media Reporting
on Education Research Award
from the American Educational
Research Association.
Emily is a member of the
Education Writers Association
Journalist Advisory Board
and was a longtime mentor for
EWA's New to the Beat Program.
For the past several years,
Emily has been reporting on
early reading instruction.
Her 2018 podcast episode,
"Hard Words, Why Aren't
Kids Being Taught To Read",
won the Inaugural Public
Service Award from the EWA.
You can find all of her
reporting on reading
at apmreports.org\reading,
including her new podcast which I think
is a major hit and it's
compelling listening;
"Sold a Story: How Teaching
Kids to Read Went So Wrong".
And I should just finally add
that I think it's very fair
to say that Emily has the
distinction of being a person
who has really changed the
national debate on a matter
of importance to everyone.
And that is,
everyone should be so lucky as to be able
to see their work have
that kind of impact.
So it's a wonderful privilege
to have Emily visiting with us today.
Welcome, Emily.
- Thank you, thank you for having me.
I've already gotten one text that says,
"You're not in your usual office."
And it's true,
I'm in New Haven.
I'm here in person.
We're all on Zoom,
but I'm here in New Haven and
I'm really glad to be here.
I've had a wonderful day so far.
I met a whole bunch of
students and faculty
and I'm really grateful
for the invitation.
So, I'm just gonna talk
for a little while.
I thought I would just tell
you a little bit about myself,
tell you sort of some of my story
about how I got interested in this topic
and some of what I have
learned about reading
and how it works and
how kids learn to do it.
'Cause actually, it's really fascinating
and I think many of you maybe don't know.
I certainly didn't know.
So you can put up the first slide.
I have some slides.
This is actually just,
the first one is just a couple of kids
in a classroom in California,
and this is the goal,
happy little readers, right.
And the question has always been,
how does a little kid get there?
How does a kid learn to read?
So you can go to the next slide.
This is my kid.
I have two kids.
I have two boys.
So this is my little one.
And when my kids went off to school,
I really didn't think about
how they were gonna be taught to read.
I definitely didn't think about
whether they were gonna be taught to read.
I just assumed they would,
and they did without much trouble.
So this is my younger one.
This is a few months after
he started kindergarten
and he's reading a
chapter book and I truly,
I don't have any idea how
he learned to do that.
It just kind of seemed to happen.
It was like magic.
And school was actually
a really good experience
for this kid.
He's now 20.
He's a sophomore in college.
And it was for my older son, too,
who's a college graduate.
It was for me, too,
and I think the fact that
school was pretty good
for us had something to do with the fact
that reading came pretty easily.
But here's the thing that I
have learned that I didn't know.
Reading doesn't come
easily to a lot of people
and it doesn't have to
do with intelligence.
There are lots of really smart people
who struggle to learn how to read.
And they can learn to read,
they can, but they really need someone
to teach them how to do it,
to show them how it works.
And there was this moment when I started
to understand this in a way
that I never had before.
And it was actually here in Connecticut.
It was the winter of 2016
and I was interviewing college students
who had been placed in
remedial reading classes.
And these were students who
graduated from high school.
They went to college and they were told,
wait a second,
you're not ready for this.
You're not ready for college.
And the instructor in one
of these classes told me
about a student that she had
had a lot of years earlier,
her name was Sarah.
And the instructor could tell
that this student was
really smart and driven
and she wanted a college degree
because she wanted to be a nurse.
But Sarah wasn't gonna be
able to pass the assessment
that was gonna get her out of
this remedial reading class.
She couldn't read very well at all.
She couldn't write.
And the instructor ended up petitioning
the English Department, saying,
"Sarah's really bright.
"She needs a college degree
so she can be a nurse.
"Let's figure out some way to assess her,
"get her out of this
class so she can move on
"and get a degree."
And it worked.
Sarah passed the class
and then this instructor
whose name is, Jill,
lost track of Sarah.
She thought about her sometimes.
She wondered about what
had happened to her.
And then years later,
Jill was in the hospital having surgery
and she woke up and there was Sarah.
Sarah was Jill's nurse.
So when I heard this story, I thought,
I really wanna talk to Sarah.
So Jill dug up an old email address.
I wrote to Sarah.
Sarah wrote back to me
and in the winter of 2016,
I drove to her house in
Connecticut in the middle
of an ice storm and we
did this long interview,
and Sarah told me all
about her reading problems.
Now, it turns out that Sarah has dyslexia.
That was not something
that was ever identified
when she was in school.
It actually wasn't anything
that was ever officially diagnosed.
It's basically what Sarah
figured out about herself.
And Sarah told me about
all these strategies
that she had to try to get
through the written text.
So there were a certain number of words
that she had just memorize.
She knew what they looked like,
like common words she saw all the time.
And then there were a lot of other words
and she would just guess them.
She would look at the first letter,
look at the last letter,
and think about something that made sense.
And she told me the problem
was she couldn't come up
with a very good guess a lot of times,
so she just skipped a lot of words.
And this way of reading
was really time-consuming.
It was hard. It was frustrating.
It was confusing.
She couldn't focus on the
meaning of what she was reading.
So really, her main strategy
with reading was just
to avoid reading.
She really didn't do it.
She had this sister who was
a little bit older than her
who would read things out loud to her
and that's really how
she got through school,
how she got through high school.
Then she got stuck
in that remedial reading class in college.
She got saved by her instructor.
She eked her way through
college without opening a book.
She told me, never,
she says she never
opened a book in college.
And her strategy was to
pay really close attention
to the lecture and the class discussion.
She says she has a really good memory,
I believe her,
and that's how she got her nursing degree.
She memorized all the words
that she needs to know
to be able to read and write,
communicate with the
nurses and the doctors
and the medical staff.
but she really never learned how to read.
And her story was really amazing to me.
I had all kinds of questions
after talking to her,
about dyslexia first of all.
I knew nothing about it,
about why she was never
identified with dyslexia,
didn't get any help in school.
So this next picture
which you're looking at,
stay on this slide,
I just started to dig into
this question of dyslexia
and learning disabilities.
And there's tons of research about this,
so this is just one little
part of my bookshelf.
These are some of the books
that I started reading.
So I was digging into the
research about dyslexia
and then I was also talking to parents.
And I was starting to hear the same story
from parents all over the country.
First I was talking to parents in Maryland
where I live and I thought,
oh my gosh,
Maryland has a terrible problem.
And then I was talking
to parents in California
and Michigan and Florida and, really,
literally, it was the same
story over and over again.
And the story is basically this.
"Our kid went to school and we
knew something wasn't right.
"We went to the teacher
and the teacher was like,
"'Don't worry, make sure you
read lots of books to him.
"'Everything's gonna be fine.'
"But we were like,
"something's not right with reading here.
"He doesn't seem to get it.
"He doesn't like it."
This went on for years.
The parents would say,
"There's something wrong here."
And the school was saying,
"Don't worry, we've just gotta
find your kid the right book.
"He'll get really excited
and it'll all be fine."
And what eventually happens,
these parents were telling me,
if they had time and money,
especially money,
money's a big thing here,
these parents would
pay for private testing
to try to figure out what's
going on with their kid.
And this usually costs
thousands of dollars.
A lot of these parents have
turn to private tutoring,
which is more thousands of dollars.
Sometimes they'd hire a lawyer
or an educational consultant
or both to actually start
a fight with the school
to try to get what their kid needed.
And it's really expensive,
really frustrating,
really hard, really exhausting.
And what happens is the
parents begin to realize
that their child isn't
gonna get what he needs
in public school or he's not
gonna get it fast enough.
'Cause now this kid is like nine,
10 years old.
He hates school.
He can't read very well
so he is falling behind
in other subjects.
Sometimes this kid is
acting out in school,
like maybe this is turned
into a behavior problem
or maybe this is starting
to manifest as anxiety,
depression, withdrawal.
And this is when the parents tell me,
if they have the resources,
time and money, money,
money, money,
the family pulls their
child out of public school.
So maybe they teach them themself.
I've met a whole bunch of
mothers who quit their careers
to teach their children to read,
to homeschool their kids.
Or maybe they come up with the, literally,
tens of thousands of dollars,
like maybe even $80,000 a year
at some schools around here
that it can cost to send a kid
to a specialized private school.
And there's a whole bunch
of parts of the country
where there isn't a good private
school to send the kid to,
even if you could get them in,
even if you did have the money.
So what I started to realize
is that we're in this situation
in this country that if you can come up
with the money to pay for it,
you can probably find a way for your kid
to be taught how to read.
But if you don't have the money
and your child is not learning
how to read in school,
what do you do?
So the equity implications
of this are really stunning.
If you're from a low-income family,
even a moderate-income family,
there's really no safety net here.
There's no backup if
you're not being taught
to read in school.
One mom said to me,
"Getting help for a struggling
reader is a rich man's game.
So I was like, whoa,
what, reading?
This is the most basic thing here.
This is the foundation upon
which all learning is built.
So how did that happen?
How is it allowed to continue?
What was going on?
So I did this next reporting project,
you can go to the next slide.
And this is what Alan
mentioned, "Hard Words".
It's an audio documentary
about core reading instruction.
So first I was really
interested in dyslexia,
what do kids with dyslexia need?
But now I was like, okay,
let's not think about
what struggling readers
need in particular,
but rather, what do all children need
to learn to become good readers?
What's up with this,
how do we learn to read?
And what I discovered is
that there's this huge body
of evidence about reading.
And the bottom line from
that evidence is this,
decades and decades of research.
What kids with dyslexia need to learn
to become good readers is
not substantially different
from what all kids need to
learn to become good readers.
We all need to learn the same things
to become good readers.
Kids with dyslexia need
a certain intense dose
of a certain kind of instruction.
But all kids can benefit
from the kind of instruction the kids
with dyslexia desperately,
desperately need.
So I started digging into all
this research about reading.
So you can go to the next slide.
So this is just a part
of my shelf of books,
the slide before this.
This is just questions
about how do we read?
How do our brains learn to do that?
How do we learn?
You know, what do we need to know?
What do we need to be taught?
Why do some people struggle with reading?
Why is learning to read
really hard for some people?
Because it is,
it's really hard for some people.
And a lot is known about this,
a lot is known about reading
and why kids struggle.
And there's actually research that shows
that different reading methods
affect reading development.
So different ways of
teaching kids to read,
you can actually see it in their brain.
So you can go to the next one.
This is a book that taught me so much
and I highly recommend this book,
"Reading in the Brain".
It's not light.
You can see,
I don't think I've ever put so
many sticky notes in a book.
And there's a big takeaway from this book
and from all this research.
And maybe it seems kind of obvious
but it wasn't obvious to me,
is that our brain is actually
the product of millions
of years of evolution in a
world without writing, right.
So as human beings,
we just didn't do this reading
and writing thing for a long time,
so our brains actually
aren't wired to do it.
We're not born with brains
that are wired to read.
It turns out that some of us don't need
to be taught that much,
we don't need very much instruction,
but some of us need a lot.
So you can go to the next slide.
This is really the book
that sort of blew my mind
about all of this.
It was written in 2017 by
a guy named Mark Seidenberg
who's a cognitive scientist at
the University of Wisconsin.
And it made me think a
whole lot about a lot
of assumptions that I didn't
realize I had about reading.
And here's a quote from the
book by Mark Seidenberg.
"Reading to children rarely
involves teaching them to read.
"The activity contributes
to the child's progress,
"but it is not all that is required.
"Some children do learn to
read with minimal instruction,
"but unlike learning to talk,
"it is a mistake to
assume that they will."
Another quote from this book is,
"Children who are read to,
"Until the Cow Jumps Over the Moon",
can still have difficulty
becoming readers.
So this book is about that,
and it's also about politics and policy
and teacher preparation
and what teachers learn,
and really, more like
what they don't learn
about how kids learn to
read and how to teach it.
It goes into the reading wars
and ideas about how kids learn to read,
theories about it that we've been fighting
about for centuries.
The "Sold a Story" podcast that I talked
to you about before,
at one point we went way back in history,
actually, we have a timeline
that starts in the 1600s.
And at one point,
we had this whole section in there
where we talked about the
reading wars back in the 1800s,
and they were just drop-down,
horrible, bitter fights.
And they really started
'cause this guy named,
Horace Mann, who you've probably heard of,
who's like the father of public education,
was the first Secretary of
Education in Massachusetts.
And he came along with this idea,
he believed in this particular method
about teaching kids to read,
and it was called the Whole-Word Method.
And Horace Mann believed this.
These are quotes from Horace Mann.
"Children learn to read by being
"in the presence of books."
And then he said this,
"I am satisfied that our greatest error,"
this is Horace Mann,
"our greatest error in teaching children
"to read lies in beginning
with the alphabet.
"No thorough reform will ever be affected
"in our schools until this
practice is abolished."
So Horace Mann did not like the idea
that kids were gonna be
taught about the letters
and the sounds that make
up the words and language.
He thought that was gonna
be tedious and boring
and that it was unnecessary.
In fact, this is one of my
favorite quotes from Horace Mann.
He said, "In regard to all
the other sources of pleasure,
"beauty, motion,
"music, memory,
"the alphabetic column
presents an utter blank.
"There stands in silence and death,
"the stiff, perpendicular
row of characters,
"lank, stark, immovable.
"They are skeleton-shaped,
"bloodless, ghostly apparitions.
"And hence it is no wonder
that the children look
"and feel so deathlike when
compelled to face them."
So I think it's important
to recognize that one
of the founders of public
education felt very strongly
about how to teach kids to read,
and he really thought it
was gonna be a bad idea
to start with letters and sounds,
to start with phonics.
He thought that was gonna be bad for kids.
And then, the Boston School masters,
and this guy named Samuel Green,
who is the principal
of the Phillips Grammar School in Boston,
were listening to Horace Mann
and reading things he was
writing and they're like,
"Whoa, whoa,
"wait a minute, Horace,
"hold your horses."
And they wrote this retort to Horace Mann,
which is fascinating,
in their very 19th century way.
And they wrote things like this:
"Reading, justly deserves the
first rank among the studies
"of our schools.
"As an accomplishment alone,
"it possesses intrinsic excellence;
"but considered as fundamental
"to other departments of learning;
"its value cannot be
too highly estimated."
So they were saying,
"Hold on, Horace,
"you are talking about
something critical here.
"You're coming up with this
new idea to teach kids to read
"and we don't think that
this is a good idea."
They said, "In judging
the merits of any system
"by which reading may be taught,
"remote, as well as an immediate effects
"should be duly regarded.
"A child, even at the
threshold of his education,
"should not be subjected to any delay,
"which the formation of
correct habits may require.
"He should never be
hurried over difficulties,
"at first concealed,
"yet, in his progress,
"unavoidable, simply to make his entrance
"into the temple of learning,
"easy and agreeable.
"A system of instruction is
subjected to an unworthy test,
"when the chief excellence
claimed for it consists
"in smoothing the path of the learner."
So essentially, Horace Mann was saying,
"Let's make this easier for kids to learn
"to read by not focusing
on the letters and sounds
"and the stuff that's hard.
"English spelling is hard.
"Let's just get kids into books and words
"and get them right there to the end."
And the Boston School masters are saying,
"Wait a second,
"you're gonna try to make
this easy at the beginning
"by just getting kids into books
"and not teaching them letters and sounds,
"putting the hard stuff on the side,
"but you are going to damage
those children in the end."
And no one could agree.
Should you start with the way
that Horace Mann was saying,
sort of meaning first, whole words,
whole sentences, whole stories,
or should you start
with letters and sounds,
a sort of bottom-up approach,
emphasized decoding, right?
And we fought about this forever
because no one really knew.
But then, all this research
started being done,
sort of exploded in the 1970s,
motivated by the question,
how do kids learn to read?
Like seriously, how does that work?
So you can go to the next slide.
And this is something I talk about a lot.
I think it's a really good place
to begin because it really,
really helped me understand
how reading works.
It's called the Simple View of Reading.
And the Simple View of
Reading does not say
that reading is simple, really important.
To the contrary,
reading is actually really
complicated, it's complex.
But the Simple View of
Reading is a simple model
to understand a complex process.
So it was first proposed a long time ago.
I was in high school.
It was 1986.
And this model was actually proposed
because these researchers were
trying to clarify the role
of decoding and reading comprehension,
because everyone was fighting about this.
This was sort of when the reading wars
of the late 20th century
were getting into full swing.
Now, everyone agrees that
the goal of reading is
to comprehend text.
Everyone agrees on that.
And the question is,
how does a little kid get there?
So the Simple View says that,
reading comprehension is the
product of two things, right.
So one is your ability to
decode the words, right.
And the other part
of the equation is your
language comprehension.
So that's your ability to
understand spoken language.
So we're not talking about
your ability to read text.
Language comprehension is your
ability to understand meaning
when someone is talking
or when text is being
read out loud to you.
So, for example,
when someone says to you,
she is reading the book,
you know what the verb
means in that sentence,
you know what she's doing.
So what the Simple View
says is that if you
have really good language
comprehension skills,
but zero decoding skills,
your reading comprehension will be zero,
because zero times anything is zero.
And the Simple View also says that if you
have really good decoding skills
but very poor language
comprehension skills,
you just don't know the meaning
of that many words in spoken language,
your reading comprehension
will not be very good either.
So, here's why this is important.
Most kids entering school have very little
when it comes to the decoding
part of the equation, right.
They have zero or close to
zero when it comes to the D
in the Simple View of Reading.
But they do have something when it comes
to the language comprehension
part of the equation.
So when kids enter school,
they know the meaning of lots of words,
if they're English speakers in America,
but they don't know how to
decode those words yet, right.
So this is why people familiar
with the science of reading,
so-called, call for an emphasis
on decoding instruction
in the early grades.
Because if the goal,
if the end goal here is to try
to get your reading comprehension,
and you have a bunch of
five and six-year-olds
who are sitting in front of you,
they have language comprehension skills,
but they really have
virtually no decoding skills,
you need to help those children
develop decoding skills.
But, and this is so important,
the Simple View clearly
shows that focusing only
on decoding would be a very,
very big mistake because it's
only part of the equation.
And, this is really important,
kids come into school
with very different language
comprehension skills, right.
Some kids know the meaning
of lots and lots of words.
Some kids are far smaller vocabularies.
Some kids are speaking
little or no English.
So reading instruction that
aligns with the Simple View has
to focus on this language
comprehension part
of the equation too.
So I was in this first grade classroom
where reading instruction
was deliberately aligned
with the Simple View,
and what I saw was phonics
instruction in one part
of the reading instruction,
and the kids were broken
into small groups,
depending on the level
of their decoding skills.
And then in another part
of the reading instruction,
they were getting explicit
vocabulary lessons
and lots of reading out
loud by the teacher.
And the words that the kids
had learned were posted
on cards all over the classroom.
They were words like,
extraordinary and
ridiculous and neighborly,
which are not words that the vast majority
of first graders are
gonna be able to decode.
They shouldn't be expected to.
But the first graders in this class
were learning the
pronunciation and meaning
of those words so that when
they're able to decode them,
they'll know what the words mean.
And this is really important,
every single child in
that class spoke English
as a second language,
and for some kids,
English was their third language.
So, this Simple View was
proposed as a model back in 1986,
and then the basics of this model
had been confirmed over and
over again by research since.
And I think it's really helpful
'cause it disentangles some of the stuff
that's really contentious
in the debates about reading
and has been for decades,
for centuries, right.
So what's known as the whole word,
which sort of became the whole language,
which is now more recently
called balanced literacy.
So in the whole language
balanced literacy view,
the focus right from the start
of reading instruction
should be on getting kids
to focus on the meaning
of what they're reading.
That's what Horace Mann wanted.
Whole language and balanced literacy
are meaning emphasis approaches
to reading instruction.
Get kids to focus on
the whole, the meaning.
As opposed to what's known
as a code emphasis approach,
which emphasizes decoding
skills at the beginning
of reading instruction, right.
So early reading instruction that aligns
with the scientific research
over the past 50 years,
is a code emphasis approach not only,
but emphasizing so that
kids can get to meaning,
because everyone agrees
that meaning is the goal.
And the question again is,
how does a little kid get there?
So, in my reporting,
what I became very interested
in trying to figure out is,
how are kids being taught in school?
That's what I started to dig into next.
So let me just tell you a
little bit about what I learned.
You can go to the next slide.
This is just one little artifact here.
It was sent to me by a
mom in Massachusetts.
It came home in her son's backpack.
And these are all
strategies for kids to use
when they're learning
to read and they come
to a word that they don't know.
And here's the thing,
these strategies make sense.
They seem totally sensible.
You get to a word you don't know,
what can you do?
Well, you can look at the picture
to try to figure out
what the word might be.
You don't wanna completely guess,
so you can look at the first letter,
like Sarah did, for example.
You can look at some of the letters.
It's gonna narrow your choices,
help you come up with a good guess.
You can then check,
you can see if you were right.
Reread the sentence using the word,
see if the sentence makes sense.
Ah, maybe you were right.
If you're really stuck,
you can just skip the word and move on.
Skip, hopefully you can get the
gist of the sentence anyway.
So what I was trying to understand is,
I was seeing stuff like
this all over the place,
like on postcards, on bookmarks,
there are these little cartoon characters
that have versions of these strategies.
This was everywhere in American schools.
I was seeing it in classrooms
that I was visiting.
I was getting sent it,
parents were telling me
about it and I was like,
what is this about?
What is the idea about how reading works
that these strategies are based on?
That's what I wanted to get interested in
and that's what I started
to try to figure out.
So you can go to the next slide.
It turns out that these
ideas are based in a theory,
a theory about reading that's
been around for a long time,
that's come to be known sort
of more recently as cueing.
Not everyone uses that term.
But the idea is that
readers use different kinds
of information or cues or clues
to identify the words as they're reading.
And this was sort of articulated
as a theory back in the 1960s,
and it was sort of a big deal.
It was a big deal in the research area
when this theory came out.
And the basic idea behind
this cueing theory,
remember this is the 1960s,
we really didn't know how people read yet,
the theory here is that readers don't have
to sound out written words
to know what they are.
They can, right,
they can sound out the words,
but they don't have to because
they can use other strategies
to figure out the words.
They can do things like look
at the first letter of a word,
use the context,
think of a word that makes sense,
look at the pictures.
They can essentially predict
the words as they're reading.
The problem is,
this is not the way that
skilled readers do it.
This is not the way that
skilled readers read.
So you can go to the next slide.
I did this reporting project
in 2019 where I was just,
I got really interested
in this cueing theory,
and how this theory and the
word-reading strategies based
on this theory became foundational
in reading curriculum,
reading assessments and
reading intervention programs
that are very popular in American schools
that say they use a
balanced literacy approach
to teaching reading.
And surveys show that most schools,
at least until recently,
said they used a balanced
literacy approach.
Cueing is at the foundation
of that balanced literacy approach,
but this cueing theory
as I said, isn't right.
It's not how skilled reading works.
Cognitive scientists showed this back
in the 1970s and '80s.
Skilled readers, when
you're a good reader,
you do not use cues and context
to identify words as you're reading.
In fact, this is the amazing thing,
what scientists figured
out is that this is
how poor readers read, right.
Struggling readers often have a hard time
with word identification.
Too many of the words that
they come across are kind
of like little mysteries,
little series of letters
that they don't know
and they can't quite figure out.
So, like Sarah,
they have all these other
strategies that they use
to try to figure out what
the words say, right.
And often, they don't like reading,
they just get a gist of the reading.
They guess and skip and use context.
This is not what reading is like
when you're a skilled reader.
What cognitive scientists
have figured out is
that this really is the key difference
between skilled readers
and unskilled readers.
Skilled readers can immediately
and accurately recognize words.
They don't need to guess or
predict or use the context.
And skilled readers,
once you're a skilled reader,
if you're a skilled reader,
you actually know tens
of thousands of words
in a split second,
like instantly on sight.
In fact, if you're a skilled reader,
your brain has gotten
so good at reading words
that you process the word
book faster than you process
a picture of a book,
which is really amazing 'cause remember,
your brain was not designed to do it.
So how did your brain get so good at that?
So I'm just gonna take
another couple of minutes
to explain another couple key concepts
and then we're gonna move on to questions.
But it happens
through this process called
orthographic mapping.
And I think it's really key
to understand a little bit
about orthographic mapping
to understand why teaching kids
how to decode words is so important,
why phonics is important, and,
why teaching kids the cueing
strategies is not a good idea.
So yes to phonics and no
to the cueing strategies.
So here's a quick and
simplified explanation
of orthographic mapping.
It's basically the process that we use
to store printed words
in our long-term memory.
And here's how you do it.
You attend closely to how
a written word is spelled
and you link that sequence of letters
to the word's pronunciation and meaning.
So it's three things, the spelling,
the pronunciation, and the meaning.
So for a very simple example,
a little kid knows the
meaning and pronunciation
of the word, cat.
And the written word, cat,
gets orthographically mapped to her memory
when she links the sounds, at,
to the written word, C-A-T.
So that requires an awareness
of the speech sounds and words,
that's called phonemic awareness.
It requires an understanding
of how those sounds are represented
by letters, that's phonics.
So you need good phonics
and phonemic awareness
to orthographically map
words into your memory.
And once a word has been
orthographically mapped
to your memory,
you know it instantly on sight.
In fact, you cannot suppress your ability
to read the word, it's fascinating.
You don't have to consciously
sound out the word
when you see it.
But you know the word in a split second
because at some point,
maybe when you were like eight
years old or five years old,
at some point you successfully
sounded the word out
and you link the spelling
of the word in your mind
with the meaning and the
pronunciation of that word.
So by about second grade,
a typically developing reader
who has good phonic skills
needs just a few exposures to a word
through its pronunciation,
its spelling and its meaning, and bam,
the word is mapped to her memory.
The more words that you map
to your memory this way,
the more you can focus on the meaning
of what you're reading.
You're not using your brain
power to identify the words,
you're using your brain
power to understand
what you're reading.
And that's the goal, right,
for readers to understand
what they read or are reading.
But, when teachers use that cueing system,
when they teach all those
word-reading strategies,
they're actually impeding that
orthographic mapping process.
So you can go to the next slide.
I'm just gonna tell you
this one little story
and then wrap up.
So these are first graders
in Oakland, California,
and a literacy coach who
worked with these girls came
to see that teaching the cueing strategies
was actually making it harder
for many of her students
to learn how to read.
The coach's name is Margaret Goldberg.
She was hired by the Oakland
Unified School District back
in 2015 to teach a program called,
Level Literacy Intervention.
LLI is a reading intervention program
that does include some
phonics instruction.
Because remember, one of the cues
for figuring out a word
is to use the letters.
But LLI is rooted in that idea,
that foundational idea
in balanced literacy,
that letters are one way
to figure out a word.
So kids are also taught
that when they come
to a word they don't know,
they can use pictures and context to try
to come up with a guess.
So Margaret started
teaching this LLI Program,
and then at about the same time,
she found this bunch of
unopened materials sitting
on a shelf in her school,
which you'll find all over America
and is part of the problem.
And it was a systematic phonics program
and phonemic awareness and it teaches kids
that when they come to
a word they don't know,
they sound it out and
it does not include any
of the cueing stuff.
And in this program,
beginning readers practice
reading in decodable books,
books that contain words with
spelling patterns they've
been taught so they don't
have to guess at the words,
they don't have to use that strategy.
So Margaret started
teaching some of her groups
of students LLI with the cueing,
and some, she taught
this systematic phonics
and phonemic awareness
program with no cueing.
And, she started to notice differences
between the two groups of kids,
not just in how well they were reading,
but in the way they
approached their reading.
So she and a colleague
recorded first graders talking
about what makes them good readers.
So this is a video,
we're gonna play it for you.
Mia is in the white shirt.
She was learning phonics and no cueing.
And Jabrea is in the pink jacket.
She was taught the cueing system.
So you can play the slide.
- [Teacher] Yes, what
makes you good readers?
- I learn a lot.
- 'Cause I look at the
pictures and I read it.
- [Teacher] Oh, do you
remember when you were little
and you didn't know how to read?
- Yes.
- [Teacher] Like when you
started kindergarten?
- Kind of.
- Yeah.
- [Teacher] What helped
you learn how to read?
How did you learn?
- By looking at the pictures.
- [Teacher] Anything else?
- Looking at the words
and sounding them out.
- So Margaret was seen
as over and over again
in these two groups of kids.
Like, one group of kids
was taking away this idea
from reading instruction,
the idea that reading is
about looking closely at words
and sounding them out.
And the other group of kids was learning
that when you come to
a word you don't know,
you don't have to look
carefully at the word
and try to connect the spelling
with the pronunciation and the meaning.
Instead, you can look away from the word
and you can look at the pictures,
you can look at the other
words in the sentence,
search around for clues to
help you identify the word.
But remember, that orthographic
mapping process requires you
to look carefully at the words
so your brain links the spelling
with the sounds and the meaning.
And this cueing stuff teaches kids
to actually look away from the words.
So what Margaret Goldberg
said to me about the kids
in her LLI groups was this,
"I did lasting damage to these kids.
"It was so hard to ever get them
"to stop looking at a picture
to guess what a word would be.
"It was so hard to ever
get them to slow down
"and sound a word out because they had
"had this experience of
knowing that you predict
"what you read before you read it."
So you can go to the next slide.
This sort of tease up the
"Sold a Story" podcast,
which is really my
effort to figure out why,
how did it happen that this
idea became so predominant
in American schools,
not just in American
schools but in schools
in other parts of the
English-speaking world too?
Like I said,
we had this unbelievable
timeline that started in 1649.
It has 2019 entries as of yesterday,
and it is about one idea.
The idea is kids don't need
to sound out written words
because they have other
ways to know what they are.
They can sound out the words
but they don't have to.
The whole thing is about
what's wrong with that idea
and how that idea came to
dominate in American schools
and the damage that idea has done.
Six episodes, four and a half hours,
that's it.
The debate about how to teach children
to read has long been about phonics
and has been understood
to be about phonics.
And getting reading instruction
right though is not just
about adding phonics instruction,
it's about taking away that cueing theory.
And I think most importantly,
helping teachers understand
what's wrong with that theory.
And I think you do that by
helping them learn how to read,
and when teachers really do learn
how kids learn how to read,
then they sit there and it
sort of falls apart on its own.
This whole cueing theory,
they're like, what,
why did I do that?
And we can get into a little bit
of that in the conversation.
But I'll just tell you a few
things about the reaction
to "Sold a Story".
It's had lots of listeners.
I think it's 5.3 million listeners so far,
lots of people who aren't educators,
who aren't the parents
of struggling readers.
That was really one of my goals.
I said to my editor early on,
I really want the moms of the
kids who aren't struggling
to write to me and say,
I listened and I care about this
and I wanna do something about it.
And that is what's happening.
I think the parents of struggling readers
have felt alone for a long time,
and they're finding each
other and there's more
of them than you realize.
And I think this is something
that all of us need to care about,
even people who learned how to read easily
in spite of how they were taught.
Another thing that "Sold
a Story" has done is
that legislators in at least 15 states
have introduced some kind of bill
to overhaul reading
instruction since it came out.
There was a big wave of
legislative effort going
on before that.
So this has really been happening
over the past several years,
and I think a lot of it has
to do with parent advocacy.
But one of the things that's
happening now in these bills is
that a lot of them are
focused on curriculum,
and some of them are specifically focused
on banning curriculum that
includes this cueing idea.
At last count as of yesterday,
there were 10 states at least
that have introduced
some kind of cueing ban,
which I have some mixed feelings about
which we can talk about.
I mean, the point of this podcast was
that this idea is debunked and harmful
and breaking its decades-long hold
on education system is really important.
But these bands make me anxious.
When you take something away,
everyone's suddenly
looking for something new.
I'm worried about,
there's sort of a rush to buy new things.
I don't think buying
something new is the answer.
I don't think a new
curriculum's gonna solve
all the problems,
'cause at the end of the day,
this is really about teacher knowledge.
Teachers teach kids.
Curriculum don't teach kids.
And banning this cueing
stuff is taking place
at a time when lots of other
books are being banned,
so I think there's a danger here
that this could all get caught up
and corrupted by partisan politics.
And we tried this once before in America
and it did get caught up and, I think,
sort of killed bipartisan politics.
So I think I'm going to skip the rest
of the stuff I was gonna say,
'cause I think I've talked too long
and I would really love
to get to your questions.
So I'll just wrap up there
and I'm looking forward
to this discussion.
- Okay, thank you so much Emily.
That was was great.
And I wanna say also,
the podcast, it's super educational
and also really interesting
and I think you really
breathe a tremendous amount
of life into the science
of reading and phonics
and orthographic mappings
and things like that.
I'm not surprised that millions of people
have listened to your podcasts
and that it's had the
impact that it's had.
I wanna remind our participants,
please ask questions.
"When will you get the opportunity
"to ask Emily Hanford a question?"
Well, now is when you'll
have that opportunity.
So please send your questions
and then Eric Patashnik
is gonna filter those
and turn them into maybe
groups of questions
and things like that for Emily.
But let me ask Emily a question,
following up on what you said at the end
of your presentation about the politics.
As you mentioned,
there's this big wave
of legislation right now
and it's doing,
as you said,
all sorts of things.
It's promoting phonics.
It's, in some cases I guess,
restricting the use of cueing.
It's fairly detailed I
would say, for legislation.
We've had a moment in the United States,
the No Child Left Behind experience,
I think, which is what
you were alluding to.
In 2002,
a bill passed under George Bush,
but it was a bipartisan bill.
I think it had like almost
90 votes in the US Senate,
almost maybe 380 or something
like that in the House.
- Unheard of in today's times,
yes.
- Yeah, right.
So big bipartisan thing.
When I think about it,
I think I may be misremembering,
but I think I even remember
Ted Kennedy standing next
to George Bush when they signed this bill.
- Definitely, it has
been photographed yes.
- Good, good. Okay.
And then the Reading First
Program that came out
of the No Child Left Behind Bill
was sort of aimed at the idea
of promoting scientifically-based
reading approaches.
And so this had a real head of steam.
This was based on a national assessment
of where the science of reading was.
And it was very far along and very close
to what you are describing.
This effort
kind of ran off the rails,
I would say.
Within half a decade or so,
it began to run off the rails,
ran off the rails.
What lessons do you draw
from that experience?
What cautions
are you led to wanna kind of remark on?
What is our takeaway from that lesson?
What's your takeaway from that experience,
to help us avoid getting into a kind of,
turning what really is something
that I think everyone
could really get behind
as the initial coalition behind
the No Child Left Behind
Acts suggests that,
what could turn this into a
partisan thing and lead to
some of the promise that we see
in this initial legislative way
of sort of not being realized?
- Yeah, well certainly for
a lot of people out there,
it's a little bit deja vu all over again.
What's happening now,
they're like, wait a minute,
didn't we do this before?
And I'll say a couple of things.
Number one, I'm convinced from
all the work that I've done
that what's happening
now wouldn't be happening
if reading Reading First hadn't happened,
in both a positive and a negative way.
So, one thing that I think is true,
so Reading First was a
basically $6 billion effort.
It was about a billion,
so we taxpayers invested
a lot of money in trying
to get the so-called science
of reading into schools.
It's really very similar
to what's happening today,
and essentially, it was
motivated by scientists
and policymakers recognizing
that there was this big gap
between research and practice,
and we knew a lot from research
and we just needed to
get this into schools.
And if we could just get this into schools
and get the right materials
into teacher's hands,
we could make a big difference.
I think what's happening
now is benefiting from that
because in every school
and every school system,
there are some people
who really's lives were
changed by Reading First.
They really did learn something about
how kids learn to read,
and they've been trying
their hardest to do that
or there's a base of knowledge there.
So there is within our
system where there's a huge,
there's a lot of turnover and all that.
There's still a base of knowledge
from a generation ago now practically.
And so, I don't think what's happening now
would be happening if we
hadn't sort of established
that baseline and all the research
that was done at that point.
The other thing that
happened I really think is
that we had a reaction to Reading First.
So a lot of what's happened
in the years since,
I think we had a decade of
really swinging really far
in a different direction.
There were a number of things
that people didn't like
about the No Child Left Behind Bill.
There were a number of things in there
that I think even the people
who made the bill recognized
were mistakes, right.
So I think that there was a
lot of reaction against that.
There was a lot of political reaction
against the Bush
administration, the Republicans.
We went from a Republican administration
to a Democratic administration.
There were a lot of things going on here.
I think mistakes were
made during Reading First.
I think a lot of it was
very top-down in nature
and I think that's a very
important lesson now,
and I think that's why we're
at a fragile moment right now.
'Cause I think a lot of the conversation
about the science of reading
right now has been coming
from the bottom-up.
There's been a lot of parent advocacy,
teachers too, saying,
hey, we have a problem here.
We need to fix this problem.
And they've been sort of
looking up and saying,
we need help from our principals,
from our superintendents,
from our state legislators.
And in some cases they were responding,
but in other cases they're saying, like,
hey, we need something,
we need help here.
And now that's happening.
So now we're starting to get
a very much of a top-down.
I think good policy,
and I think for the political
scientists on the call,
I think ultimately good policy comes
from some really delicate
balance between these two things.
So I think we're in the
midst of that right now.
But I think it's important, I mean,
I think there were some
things that were heavy-handed
and too top-down about Reading First,
so I think we need to be
careful about top-down stuff.
But again, top-down is because
people below need the help.
I think that Reading First,
the story about Reading First,
and I think this actually
happened in practice
in a lot of places,
is that it sort of focused
too much on the decoding part.
One of the reasons I decided to give you
that whole explanation
about how kids learn
to read is I want you to understand
that this is not just
about phonics, right.
That language comprehension part is huge.
I want people to understand
that you can't just add phonics
'cause that's not enough.
And you can't just add
phonics without taking
away the stuff that isn't right
about the whole language theory.
So I think in Reading
First time went large,
we probably just didn't
do enough of the work
on the language comprehension
and the cueing stuff didn't go away.
We didn't actually lose the
adherence to the basic beliefs
in the whole language approach.
And I think maybe now,
maybe the conversation about this
and the research itself is sort
of becoming more nuanced
and sophisticated,
that I'm hopeful that we
might be at a good moment.
And I'll say one last
thing about the politics.
I do think that Reading
First became associated with,
because it was a George Bush,
you know, it was a Republican
and phonics has always been
seen as sort of traditional
and conservative and old-fashioned.
And as soon as that got
associated with phonics
and the George Bush administration,
it was easy to dismiss.
If you were progressive,
if you were liberal or whatever,
it was like push that away.
What I'm hoping is gonna mediate it now is
that this is really
important to a lot of people
who have a very,
very wide set of political beliefs.
So if you just look at my Twitter feed,
it's got people on the far left
and people on the far right
and everywhere in between,
and I love that.
(Emily chuckling)
I love that there is that
wide swathe of people
who are really interested in this.
So I hope that what will happen
here is that if it starts
to get taken by one party or another,
that there'll be a force being like, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
If you overhear on the
far right wanna take this
as your issue,
I'm not gonna let you do that.
I am over here on the far left
and this issue is mine too.
Same thing, someone gets
very far left about this,
no, no, no, no,
this is my issue too.
I'm hoping that that's
what's gonna happen,
but it's possible I'm
being too optimistic.
- Great, well thanks again.
Thank you for that response, Emily,
and again, thank you for
such an engaging talk.
We have a bunch of questions, and again,
I wanna encourage people,
we have a bunch of questions
and I hope we'll get
to a bunch more.
So please ask your questions?
With that, I wanna turn
it over to Eric Patashnik,
who has been processing the question flow.
- Thank you, it's a
real pleasure to be here
and we've received lots
of comments from people
who said that Emily's podcast was amazing,
and I certainly will echo that.
It is a phenomenal
experience to listen to it
and so encourage everyone to do that.
So, one of the questions,
Emily, was about your podcast
and where Lucy Caulkins referenced
classroom literacy practices
in the '70s and '80s
as the antithesis of
exciting and beautiful.
And so the question is,
"Is one of the reasons
"why science of reading
wasn't getting much traction
"was its image problem,
"that there was an impression
"that classroom practices
associated with it
"are kind of boring and are
not gonna stimulate children?
"How important do you
think that dimension was
"to why it didn't gain more traction
"in schools around the country?"
- Yes, I think that is a good observation
and I think that is definitely part of,
I think, that the science of reading did
and maybe still does have a
little bit of an image problem.
I will also say that I
think it's really important
when people are talking
about something that's boring
to think about who is it boring for?
I think in some cases this
stuff is boring for the adults,
but not necessarily
boring for the children.
If you are in a classroom
where kids are really learning
how to read and cracking the code,
they're pretty excited about that.
And I think some of us can even remember,
I know people can remember those moments
where it clicked for them where
they were finally reading.
It's an incredibly
powerful and exciting thing
for a child to begin to learn how to read.
It's really just like a big life moment.
And I think that a lot of the,
what we know is that
there's a significant amount
of just details that
kids need to understand
in repetition and practice
that can look boring
and rote from the outside,
but if it's effective,
if it is getting kids to
where they need to be,
remember the question I kept asking,
how does a little kid get there?
And the question is,
you're not gonna love reading,
it's not gonna be a joyful,
beautiful experience if you can't do it.
And it is not a joyful,
beautiful experience for
a lot of kids in a lot
of classrooms where they're
really being expected
to figure out a lot of
this stuff on their own.
They're being given sort of big,
broad instruction and some strategies
to figure out the words,
and it all adds up for some kids,
but for a lot of kids it doesn't add up.
And again, I wanna go back
to the equity issue here.
There are some kids
who get the help they
need outside of school,
but there are a lot of kids who don't.
And so we're really I think dramatically
widening
gaps,
opportunity gaps, very
early on in education
when we don't teach kids directly
and explicitly the things we want them
and need them to know.
- Great, another question,
here's a two-parter and that is,
"Are there particular
phonics or decoding programs
"that the experts who study the
science of reading advocate,
"that really identify and say,
"these are the best practices?
"And then, secondly,
"what would be the advice you would offer
"to somebody who finds that the schools,
"perhaps the schools
their children are in,
"is resistant to moving away
from the cueing curriculum?
"What kinds of advocacy
strategies are you finding
"are most effective on the ground?"
- So the first question
about programs I get all the time
and I'm reluctant to answer that.
Number one, I'm not hiding anything.
I don't really even know
if I know the answer
to that, right.
But I think people's immediate
question is, well what do I buy?
What do I need to get?
And I always wanna tell everyone, hold on,
let's make sure you really understand
what you're looking for.
So I do think there are some
places that really do lay out
what are the kinds of things
you wanna see in a curriculum.
And I think those are important.
There's an organization
called the Reading League
and they do have like some rubrics
where you can go through
and evaluate curriculum.
There are some entities that
actually evaluate curriculum.
There are some states that
are starting to do that.
I mean, Massachusetts is nearby.
They're starting to have their own system
where it's called, CURATE,
where they're going through
and looking at curriculum.
And I think they're really looking at it
with the sort of science
of reading in mind.
There are some other
organizations that do it
that more look at whether
or not they kind of align
with the common core standards,
which isn't exactly the same as looking at
whether they really align
with the science of reading,
but EdReports is an
organization that does that.
So I think it's important to
just know what questions
to ask of a curriculum.
So, I know that's maybe
an unsatisfying answer,
but also, as a journalist,
I never wanna endorse products anyway.
On the question,
I hear this all the time from
parents who are concerned
and are getting resistance
from their schools.
And I would say,
find the other parents who
have the same questions
and concerns you have
because they're there.
And so, find them,
and it's so much better
to go to the school
with more than one of you.
I also think many parents have gone
to the school with these questions,
and it's just them sort
of against the school.
I mean, they literally walk into a meeting
and there's like eight people, and them.
And they get sort of this
eduspeak that they don't
understand and then they leave,
feeling like they're in
an alternate reality.
And it's like,
I think my kid is having trouble reading,
but they're telling me all this stuff
and I understand what they're saying
and they're saying it's not a problem,
and I know that it is.
So find the other parents who are trying
to ask questions and go with them.
And I guess take advantage of the moment
because I think there is a
growing awareness of this.
And so there's now a lot of resources,
not just the reporting I've done,
but there's a tremendous amount
of stuff that's been written
that's really easy to digest
and read and pass around.
There are teachers who are
writing really great blogs.
There are cognitive
scientists who are starting
to really learn how to
translate this into practice.
I think that's part of the problem too,
it still is.
Research into practice is very difficult.
It takes a long time for
research to get into practice
and where the science of reading
is really well established.
I think it's less well
established and well tested
that we have lots of
great curriculum out there
that we know really work.
We don't, because part of the problem is
that balanced literacy
has been so predominant.
It's really what the market wanted.
It's what all the
publishers were creating.
It's what people were buying.
So there's not a huge number of options
when it comes to stuff
that's better aligned
with the science of reading.
So I think we're in a moment now
where the market's shaking out.
We're gonna see a lot
of products get revised.
We're gonna see new products out there
and I think some of
these things will be good
and they need to be tested,
and a lot of them haven't been tested yet.
- Great, we received a
couple of questions about,
people wanted to know
how the lessons apply
to particular groups of students
who might have special needs.
So, for example,
multilingual students, or students
who lack a rich vocabulary.
Are there any ways in which the findings
of this research suggest
that teaching should be
modified for those groups,
or are what you're finding that it works
for all groups of students?
- Well, again,
it's one of the reasons why I spent time
on that Simple View of Reading.
'Cause I think if you even just
think about those questions
and then think about the
Simple View of Reading,
you can kind of find your answer, right.
So there are two big
things that are involved
in beginning to reading comprehension,
your decoding ability,
your ability to read those written words,
and your language comprehension.
So you clearly have
some kids, for example,
a kid who doesn't speak English,
who's gonna need more,
a lot more on the language
comprehension side.
They're just gonna need
a heavy dose of that
and they are not gonna
do well in a classroom
that is not providing a good base of that,
and where they're even
getting more help, right.
So you want lots of conversation,
lots of reading out loud,
lots of talking,
lots of oral language,
but they need the decoding too.
There's no difference.
They still need to learn how
to decode those written words.
If you think about it,
they don't have the benefit
of the oral language ability
in that moment that it clicks.
Like, oh yeah, I know that word.
They might be learning the meaning
of the word at the same time.
Same thing for kids who just might not
have a lot of vocabulary, right,
and this is why getting that
part of it is so important.
What is actually really kind of crazy
about all this is teaching kids how
to read the words is
arguably the easy part,
and that's the part that we've
really been getting wrong
and we've been arguing about for so long.
That is actually arguably
easier than all the rest of it.
The language comprehension, the knowledge,
all that stuff that it takes to comprehend
what you read requires years of schooling
and is particularly
susceptible to differences
in background, right.
So what you know,
the words you know isn't just
what you learn in school.
In fact, most of what you learn
is just in your daily life,
what's going on in your home,
who are you getting a chance to talk to,
what are the things
you're getting exposed to,
all of that kind of stuff.
So really equalizing things
on the language comprehension
side is more difficult.
We will probably always see
that reading comprehension is associated
with family background
and sort of opportunities
for language comprehension.
But I would just keep going back
to the Simple View of Reading.
Again, it doesn't say reading is simple,
it's a Simple View,
a simple way to understand
a complex process.
But I think it helps disentangle
what does a second-language learner,
what does a kid who doesn't
have a huge vocabulary need,
all that kind of stuff.
- We also received a, I guess,
a cognitive science question.
And that is,
somebody who wanted to know
whether you could compare
the process that goes on in the brain
with learning to read,
with learning to read music?
Is that similar or different?
- I can't answer that question.
I certainly know that learning
to read music is used often
as a metaphor in terms of the question
of the explicit
instruction that what needs
to learn to read music.
Literally how that goes on in the brain,
I don't know.
But I think that's fascinating.
- And then, a follow-up is,
"Is there a parallel
"to the science of reading
to math instruction?
"Do you know anything about
the state of our effort
to provide evidence-based math instruction
in the schools today?
- Well, I showed you that book,
"Reading in the Brain",
and that guy, Stanislas,
and I'm gonna pronounce his name wrong.
He's French, but it's D-E-H-A-E-N-E.
The first book he wrote,
maybe it's not the first book,
but before he wrote that book
about "Reading in the Brain",
he wrote a book about math.
I'm forgetting what it's
called at the moment.
And I would say, so yes,
there is a lot of research about math
and how we learn math and
how that works in the brain.
And I think that math
instruction suffers from some
of the same problems that
reading instruction has.
And it has to do with the question,
with a sort of resistance
in American education,
generally, to sort of explicit
and direct instruction.
I would say the sort of
emphasis in instruction
has more been on
individual learning, learning on your own,
discovering things for yourself,
a more progressive approach,
which I think is wonderful.
That's what I wanted for my kids,
when my kids were little, for sure.
But I really think that it
leaves a lot of kids behind.
There are things that we can explicitly
and directly teach to
kids that we should be,
and it doesn't have to be rote,
old-fashioned, boring,
abusive, any of these,
whatever these ideas are that people have
in their head about that.
It doesn't have to be done that way.
It's not being done that way.
There are lots of schools where this kind
of instruction is being done really well.
But I think that math and reading suffer
from the same idea that
somehow we don't want
to explicitly teach
little children things,
that we want them to
discover it on their own,
that we think that that's better.
And the cognitive science
research does not show
that to be true,
not better and not more efficient.
And efficiency matters here.
Efficiency really matters with reading
'cause it's a multiplicative,
it's an exponential thing, right.
So you start to get good at reading
and you get better and better
and better at it by reading.
And the kids,
you just spiral up.
There's this thing called the
Matthew Effect in reading,
right, the rich get richer,
and it happens really fast.
Kids who get off to a
good start in reading,
like reading and then do
it more and like it more
and get better at it and do it more.
And most of what you know about language
and the vocabulary you know
and the knowledge comes from reading.
So if you get to, often,
not a good start with
reading, it's frustrating,
it's hard and you don't like it,
you resist it,
you are falling so far behind.
Not because you're falling behind,
you're just like slightly getting,
you're going like this and
your peers are going like this.
This is the achievement
gap in America, right here.
- Emily, I'm sorry,
could I just follow-up just
quickly on the math point.
I'm wondering,
I don't know,
is there a parallel
podcast to be made
about math instruction that, you know,
here's what we're doing in the schools
and here's a narrative
about why it happened
and why it makes sense?
- Yes.
- Okay.
(men chuckling)
- Yes, and I think
someone else should do it
because I have a whole bunch
of things I still wanna do about reading.
- No, I hear you.
(Emily chuckling)
But what I mean is,
is there the same level,
but not yet surfaced to this degree,
the same level of scientific foundation
for thinking about how
we teach basic numeracy
that hasn't yet filtered--
- Yes.
- Into the teacher training
and instruction, please?
- Yes. I think that,
yes, I think that is the case yes.
- Wow.
That's breaking, I'm not a journalist but
that strikes me as somewhat
noteworthy, actually.
(people chuckling)
Yeah.
- Well, I don't that there's
quite the same level.
Again, I'm not an expert in that area.
I know some about it.
So I don't know that
there's the same level
or amount of research and I don't think,
well, I was just gonna say there hasn't
been the equivalent of a
national reading panel,
but that's actually not true.
There have been some big synthesis reports
about math instruction.
So yes, I actually think
this is really a story
that needs to be dug into.
- Well, fortunately there's a number
of people in the audience, maybe.
- Yeah, journalism students.
- That wanna
take on that challenge.
- Journalism students,
soon-to-be Yale grads,
go for it.
- Thanks a lot.
- So there are a number
of questions, I think,
of people just really trying to understand
what this really means in
practice for their children.
Perhaps they've already been
exposed to cueing approaches.
So one question was,
"Exposure to rhyming books,
"is that okay?"
Another one, "Is it okay
"if young readers memorize
sight words in addition
"to sounding out words,
"is that effective as long
as they're not looking
"at pictures as cues?"
People are really, I think,
trying to understand.
"How do I know if my child,
"if somebody I care about
is learning correctly
"and when should I be concerned
that they're being taught
"in a way that might
undermine their development
"as effective readers?"
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, I mean,
it's true that I think when
you point out these things,
it's makes a lot of sense
that people get very anxious
and nervous about it.
I will say one thing,
so lots of kids are very resilient, right.
And lots of kids, really,
they can be taught this cueing stuff
and they will figure out
that the sounding out part,
that one cue,
that's the best, most effective,
most efficient, most accurate
way to know the words,
and they get that and
they start doing that.
I have to say that I've
talked to a lot of tutors,
reading tutors, who
work with middle school
and high school kids.
Sometimes this stuff really reveals itself
when kids are first taking
the ACT and the SAT,
because it's like a huge
amount of reading really fast.
That's when some of those
reading problems really
get revealed for the
first time to parents.
And they take them to
tutoring and the tutors say
that breaking these
habits are really hard,
and they have to really work
on breaking the habit first.
And this cueing stuff is stuff
that you don't even
necessarily need to be taught.
It's what a lot of readers
will come up with on their own
in the absence of being
taught how to read the words
and they can't figure it out.
That said, you know,
kids are resilient.
And people, human beings
are very responsive
to good instruction.
So I think good instruction really can
and does work and works at all ages.
I've talked to a number of adults
who really were subliterate
into their forties
and fifties and got some good instruction
and really were able to read.
Rhyming books are fantastic.
There's all kinds of things
that if you think about.
Rhyming books are really about language
and the facility with language
and understanding words
and those are really good and fine.
Do you want that to be what you're using
when you're trying to teach
kids how to decode words?
No, because it's gonna be too
easy for them to get them,
based on the rhyme, right.
So it depends.
It's like for what purpose?
There are certain books
and certain activities
for certain purposes.
On the question of memorizing words.
So, no.
I think that one of the
things we really do know is
that whole idea of just flashcards,
memorize the words,
it's not the most
efficient and effective way
to learn the words.
Is it gonna be damaging to all kids?
Absolutely not, because
some of those kids really
are teaching themselves
the code through that.
They're memorizing the words.
They're putting together the spelling,
the sound of the meaning
and it's making sense.
But that is not a good sign if
what your kid is being asked
to do in school is just
memorize a lot of words,
because that is actually not the best,
most efficient way to store
them in your long-term memory.
Now again, some kids really
are teaching themselves
and they can use these pattern books
and they can be taught
the cueing strategies
and all of that exposure,
they put it together and they're good.
It's almost like magic,
like my kids.
- So, I'll ask a question
myself if that's okay.
So thanks to your amazing
podcast and parental advocacy,
we are seeing more and
more states that are trying
to promote science of reading
and to eliminate cueing
strategies and to be effective.
But, of course at the end of the day,
this still actually has to
happen in the classroom.
Teachers have to change in
some cases the way they've
been teaching for many years.
How difficult is that?
How much professional
development is required?
How many hours of training?
What are the challenges to actually,
if a state has already made a commitment?
They've listened to your podcast,
the parents came to the school board,
they said, we absolutely wanna do this,
how hard will it be to go
from that commitment at a policy level,
to actually making sure this happens
in classrooms consistently
over the long run?
- Hard?
(Emily chuckling)
I think it's gonna be very hard
and I really worry about that.
I mean, yeah.
It's gonna be very hard
'cause this is a really big
amount for teachers to learn.
There are a lot of things that they need
to unlearn along the way.
I'll just sort of report on
what teachers have told me.
I hear from teachers all the time.
It's almost like these
stages of grief about this.
Often, they resist at first,
like, oh no, no, no,
that can't be.
I've been teaching kids this way,
and a lot of them are doing fine,
and a lot of them were doing fine, right,
'cause a lot of kids do fine,
depending on where you are, right.
You might have most of the
kids in your class are fine,
no matter how you teach,
and in other places you
might have a lot more kids.
So many teachers though have been like,
you know, I had a gut level feeling
that something wasn't right.
And a lot of times they blame themselves.
I wasn't doing it well enough.
I wasn't doing good enough job,
so I'm gonna work really hard,
I'm gonna go to more
professional development,
I'm really gonna do this.
They work hard,
do everything they're supposed to do
and a lot of the kids
still aren't learning.
So what do you do?
Oh well, it must be the kids.
They're not working hard enough.
They're lazy, they're
not trying hard enough.
Oh, maybe he has a reading disability.
Oh, her mother didn't read
to her enough at home.
Poor girl, she doesn't have
enough books in her home.
And so when teachers
start to learn about this,
they start to realize,
oh my god,
I was blaming myself,
I was blaming the families,
I was blaming the kids,
but there was a lot of
stuff I didn't know.
And now I have a huge
amount I need to know.
And so, a lot of teachers
are making investments
of a huge amount of their time,
and in some cases their money,
to go learn this stuff.
And teaching is a hard job.
We ask so much of our teachers.
The work conditions aren't great.
We don't pay them enough.
This is not easy.
There are plenty of teachers
who are resisting this
for good reason.
And one of the reasons
they're resisting it is, like,
I have heard you telling me before
that this is the new thing I have to learn
and the new thing I have to
do and I am not interested.
I'm gonna close my door and do
what I've always been doing.
And in some cases,
what they've always been doing is great.
They figured this out
long ago and were teaching
and they were trying
to resist all the fads
and all the things going on.
Unfortunately, we'd love to
be able to tell teachers,
close your doors
and just make your own
professional decisions.
But so many teachers haven't
learned what they need to know
about how kids learn to read
and they're recognizing that.
So I think this is a really,
really big challenge.
I guess I will just say,
I'm hopeful at the moment
because I think there are a lot
of people out there who
are really committed to it,
'cause it's so important.
- Emily, I just wanna say one
of the participants recommended,
I guess,
I don't know what it is.
It's a website, I guess.
Chalk & Talk,
with an ampersand.
- Yeah.
- Anna Stokke on mathematics education.
- On math, okay.
- Yeah.
And I just wanted to know,
are there any sources that you turn to
or that you find especially interesting,
any internet websites that you would say
if someone wants to know
more about this other,
that you would recommend they turn to that
additional information?
- Sure, if you go
to the "Sold a Story" webpage,
which is soldastory.org,
there's a reading list there
and I just put 10 things on it.
I literally could've put a hundred.
But if you start with those 10 things,
you can go down a rabbit hole for the rest
of your life if you want to,
if you just follow the footnotes.
There's one paper on there
that has like 250 references
or something so you'll be good.
- Fantastic.
And we're coming to the end of our time,
so are there any sort of observations
or anything you'd like to say kind of
to round out our discussion?
- Wow, okay.
Well, thanks for being interested in this.
I know people are
interested in it for a bunch
of different reasons and so I appreciate
whatever reason you bring to the table.
Whether it's your own child,
whether you're a teacher and
are trying to learn better,
whether you're a student who
wants to become a teacher
or go into education policy
or go into education research,
I do think this is sort
of an all-hands-on-deck kind of situation,
and I promise you that this
stuff is really fascinating.
Just at an intellectual level, for me,
doing this work over the
past five or six years
has been so gratifying
'cause it's just really interesting stuff.
So I encourage you to go to
that reading list and dig in.
It's just a fascinating topic.
- Awesome, thank you so much Emily.
I just wanna say from all the people
at the Institution for Social
and Policy Studies there,
I've said the name of
the center that I direct,
(people chuckling)
would like to just thank you so much.
You've spent the day here,
meeting with faculty and students,
and everyone I've spoken
with has been really inspired
by hearing about all the
things that you've done
and all of your insights into
this important social problem.
So let me just say thanks
again to the audience.
Thanks for everyone for attending
and for your excellent questions.
Tremendously grateful
to you for your time,
Emily, and Eric.
My good friend Eric,
thank you for your help
with the questions.
You're so good at this
and I really am grateful
to you for agreeing to
take on this responsibility
and doing it so nicely.
I encourage you to visit the ISPS website,
isps.yale.edu.
You can go there to keep
up with all ISPS events
and research and look for
announcements about future events.
Again, that's isps.yale.edu.
You can also follow us
on Twitter, @ispsyale.
That's @ispsyale.
Again, thank you all for attending.
Thanks again to our incredible staff,
especially Pam Green, Rick Harrison,
and Kira Wisher who helped with
the arrangements associated
with Emily's visit and today's webinar.
With that, I conclude today's event.
Have a great evening and I look forward
to seeing the participants
at future ISPS events.